on parle de ce sondage 71 % des Français
juste que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est un
danger pour la République euh on non
mais cyil moi je faut faut juste
expliquer pourquoi il fait ça oui il est
pas fou il a lui-même donné la clé de du
mystère il a dit la dernière fois il m'a
manqué 400000 voix voilà je vais aller
chercher ces 400000 voix où il le dit
lui-même dans les quartiers donc il il
compte à la fois sur des nouveaux
électeurs et des anciens électeurs
égarés comme Gilles Verdez ce qui est ce
qui est particulièrement d'ailleurs
insultant pour les musulmans parce que
ça veut dire je trou insultant je trouve
c'est insultant pour les car et ben oui
parce qu'il pense que tous les musulmans
sont des islamistes en fait c'est ça le
calcul de de Mélenchon donc non
seulement il est insultant envers la
gauche il a trahi toutes les valeurs de
gauche et il est insultant envers les
gens dont il veut obtenir les
voix la plart des musulmans avec qui je
parle et ils veulent juste un truc ils
veulent un État palestinien un état
israélien ils veulent que les
Palestiniens veent que les il veulent
que les Palestiniens puissent vivre en
paix dans un territoire où ils peuvent
vivre correctement
et avec des moyens et ils veulent un
État d'Israël voilà souverain et qui
puisse aussi vivre
correctement jeanluc Mélenchon il se
trompe complètement sur les quartiers et
je vous dis et dans les quartiers j'ai
encore eu encore je vous dit il y a pas
il y a pas de problème dans les
quartiers actuellement ce que je sais
pour l'instant il y a pas de problème
dans les quartiers donc Mélanchon se
plante et j'espère que sa stratégie ne
marchera pas il se plante d'autant plus
que cette semaine la BBC a diffusé un
documentaire réalisé à Gaza avec avec
une femme qui avait perdu une bonne
partie de sa famille et qui disait tout
ça c'est de la faute des chiens du Hamas
c'est une phrase qui dont vous entendrez
parler elle a dit elle a elle a qualifié
les le Hamas de chien du Hamas c'est
quoi la nouvelle idée de de la France
insoumise non je voulais tout à l'heure
dire que la dernière idée de la France
insoumise c'est à propos de la de la
presse et de la la polémique sur
Guillaume muris c'est de créer un
conseil de surveillance de la presse
c'est-à-dire que moi ça me rappelle tout
simplement les talibans au début début
2000 lorsqu'ils avaient créé le
ministère de la de de la vertu de la
justice et de la vertu et qui disait à
qui voulait bien entendre ce qu'il
fallait dire ou ne pas dire c'est
exactement la même chose on est en train
de prendre une direction qui est
dramatique LFI sa dernière proposition
c'est une création d'un conseil de
surveillance de ce qui on pourra dire
dans la presse voilà évidment ça n'est
qu'une proposition pour le moment mais
on voit bien la direction qu' sont en
train de prendre juste d'un mot ce qui
me choque moi c'est qu'il a les bons et
les mauvais journalistes retrouver les
propos que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a prononcé
à l'encontre de Karine bcard adjoint du
chef de service politique de France
Inter qui l'a invité il refuse d'aller à
son émission mais regardez les mots
qu'il utilise pour qualifier une
journaliste du service public alors il y
a les bons il y a les bons humoristes il
y a les mauvaises humoristes il y a les
bons journalistes et les mauvaises
journalistes je suis désolé dans notre
pays il y a des journalistes et on
respecte les journalistes on peut tre en
désaccord avec les journalistes mais il
y a pas d'un côté les bons parce que ils
disent que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
formidable et que LFI c'est le parti
politique le meilleur non on respecte
les journalistes dans une démocratie
ouais alors euh qui oui ch qu'est-ce qui
se passe non mais quand Éric dit que
c'est honteux parce qu'il va chercher
dans les quartiers les 400000 voix qui
lui manquent il fait de la politique
Mélenchon il fait de la politiqueis
désolé est-ce que est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on fait de la politique dans un
moment comme celui-là c'est ce que mais
est est-ce que tu acceptes qu'on fasse
de la politique dans un moment comme
celui-là non mais il fait de la
politique après moi je suis pas le
porte-parole de Jean-Luc Mélanchon il Le
Vot musul mais non mais quand vous dites
islamiste les musulmans Islamist ça
c'est de la phraséologie pour diaboliser
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce que vous allez
obtenir de mon point de vue c'est que
les gens il avait fait 68 % du vote
musulman la prochaine fois ce sera 95 %
du vote musulman parce que les musulmans
mais oui mais les musulmans ne vont plus
se reconnaître qu'en lui c'est ça Gill
toi tu vas voter pour Jean-Luc si je
voulais non mais moi je me dérroe pas
s'il est le candidat de l'Union de la
gauche il sera arrte arrête de tourner
autour du pot bah je tourne pas autour
du pot je vous répond franchement c'est
pas sûr qu'il y a une union de la gauche
il aura peutêtre différente adère à quoi
de son programme alors vu qu'il n'ose
pas nommer les choses quand elles sont
effroyabl mais moi je vote à gauche donc
je vote en citoyen disciplin à gauche
c'est l'extrême gauche c'est pas la même
chose sil est le candidat je peux pas le
dire plus clairement s'il est le
candidat de l'Union de la gauche je vote
pour lui que tu es islamiste pardon le
candidat des Islamist c'est pas le
candidat mais arrê quand on veut pas
qualifier le Hamas de mouvement vous
faites de la politique là c'est pas bien
ce que vous faites ce qui est incroyable
c'est que moi g j'étais convaincu que tu
étais de gauche gauche humaniste c'est
quoi la gauche humaniste c'est la gauche
à l'ancien la gauche humaniste et ce la
gauche sociale pluseors comment tu peux
GAE n'existe
plus donc elle bah tu es d'accord avec
moi la gauche n'existe
plus la gauche de Mélenchon c'est de
l'opportunisme pour moi c'est de la
récupération politique tu dis que c'est
de la politique c'est de la récupération
qu'il est en train de faire il a
complètement glisser on le voit
exactement le mec se dit tiens où est-ce
que je vais er a raison où est-ce que je
vais aller récupérer les voix qui me
bque il prend les musulmans pour des
cons exactement ce qu'il fait en ce
moment et c'est de la récupération
politique et c'est extrêmement dangereux
moi c'est mon avis guum tu es d'accord
avec le sondage sû qu' divise la France
oui je suis d'accord avec le sondage
mais je pense qu'il fait il fait une
récupération et une instrumentalisation
de ce conflit qui est dégueulasse qui
vise à monter les gens les uns contre
les autres qui fait plein de
sous-entendus qui encore une fois sont
dégueulasses qui sont ABS qui
sous-entend que tous les musulmans
seraient antisémites qui qui qui voilà
donc je je pense qu'il est extrêmement
dangereux je pense que son calcul est
mauvais et je pense aussi qu'il y a
plein de gens qui ont voté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui aujourd'hui sont très
déçus parce qu'il découvrent son vrai
visage et d'ailleurs on voit bien que
dans son propre parti les gens se
désolidarisent et depuis quelques mois
maintenant c'est la catastrophe à cause
de lui donc j'ai une question pour
est-ce que tu penses que 29% des
Français pensent qu'effectivement le
Hamas n'est pas une organisation
terroriste non mais moi je suis en
désaccord avec ce qu'il a ditant
tuve
et posé une question très très
intéressant tout à l'heure qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait que fasse Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour que tu ne votes pas pour
lui h là il a fait une erreur historique
il faudrait pas qu'il en fasse d'autres
comme ça une erreur historique ça vous
suffit pas pour changer votre vote
parfait parfait je va non ça ne suffit
pas pour faire changer ma voix sur la
police sur la police sur la poli sur la
police qui dit sur la police et la façon
dont il a parlé au policiers sur mon
plateau ça suffit pas je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui sur la police je ne
suis pas d'accord avec lui je ne suis
pas d'accord avec lui mais Cyr moi mais
mais là vous m'engueulez vous me tombez
dessusle pas d'accord aveci sur Mo je
mais moi je vote à gauche moi je vote à
gauche
laissez-mo la lo parce que je vote à
gauche P
à tap sur il y a des gens qui votent à
droite avec des hommes politiques on
fait des dingueries à droite des
dingueries vous regardez sur internet
des mecs on été condamné et les gens on
pas changé de vote ils ont continué à
voter à droite des mecs on é en prison
sont sortis de prison des gens oné pour
debern%
oui euh moi je suis très mal à l'aise
avec ce sondage et je suis très mal à
l'aise sur le fait de donner un oui ou
un non pourquoi parce que pour moi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon effectivement a fait
une très très grave erreur de ne pas
dire que c'est des terroristes en
revanche ce qu'il a fait et c'était le
précurseur c'est de dire au tout début
oui ce qui s'est passé en Israël c'est
horrible il y avait un émoi mondial et
tout ça mais qu'est-ce qu'il en a été à
la base de la Palestine donc c'est quoi
c'est qui de l'œuf ou de la poule si
c'est ça et c'est pour ça que grâce à
lui il y a eu des marches parce comprend
pas ce que tu dis en fait non j'ai pas
compris c'est quoi le rapportve début de
la Palestine laiss-moi laisse-moi mais
parce que ce qui a été fait en Palestine
avant on n parlait pas oui mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec un acte terroriste
attentat un attentat S a
des il y avait un foisonnement non mais
s'il vous plaît en fait il y avait un
foisonnement de manifestation pour
l'Israël lui a pu mettre en place des
manifestation pour la Palestine et c'est
grâce à ça il a des gens d'un côté
attends c'est grâce à ça qu'en
conclusion on est tous d'accord pour
dire
aujourd' pas
moi et c'est grâce à G excuse-moi je
encore par
depubut c'est parce que il y a des gens
comme ça d'un côté il y a des gens de
l'autre que aujourd'hui en conclusion
peut dire on veut juste des marches pour
la pai pas Mar pour la servir à
ça veut pas la
pit oui je com je comprends pas t t
point de vue en fait tu justif une
action terroriste sous prétexte que ça
se passait mal avant en fait c'est ça
l'idée non mais pas du tout moi j'essaie
juste de comprendre ce qu'il voulait
dire je t'ai dit je t'ai dit que le
Hamas effectivement il a fait une erreur
de dire que c'est pas terroriste en
revanche eu ce qu'il disait il disit
attendez il se passe ça est-ce qu'on
peut pas aller dans
l'antérioritétion faites attention parce
que quand il y a des crimes d'une
barbarie sans nom quand on voit ce que
j'ai vu je suis allé au camp de Choura
je vois une la secouriste qui me dit
regardez on a vu un ama de chair je
pensais que c'était une femme brûlée il
font un IRM le lendemain elle apprend
que c'est une femme et son bébé brûle et
vif vous pouvez pas dire Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a la vertu de nous ramener
dans le temps long de l'histoire il y a
quelque chose qu' l' à dépasser le
conflit israëlo-palestinien ce n plus
faites vraiment un raccourci sur ce que
je je vous dis faites attention non je
dis faites atten attention atttion non
mais attendez est-ce que quelqu'un ne
comprend pas français en fait
on comprend très bien moi je pense que
tu es en train de commettre une erreur
très importante c'est que tu tombes dans
le piège idéologique de
Mélenchon qui tombe dans le panneau de
Mathilde pas du tout non mais je je dis
que je dis je dis ça Cyril parce que
justement Mélenchon veut tout faire pour
nous obliger à être soit d'un côté soit
de l'autre et ça n'est pas le sujet on
te parle
d'humanité tout le monde sait excuse-moi
tout le monde sait que je ne suis pas
une pro Mélanchon et je vais encore une
fois repréciser mon il a fait une grave
erreur de dire que ce n pas terror
rcheiss
par pass
avant en revanche c'est le premier qui a
dit les gars juste on est sur
les- dire aussi que la Palestine a le
droit de faire ses manifestations et
tout ça et moi j'ai dit bien sûr israë
ao de fa manifestation mais la Palestine
aussi je crois que tu étais d'accord
avec moi maintenant si au lieu de
choisir son camp de foot on pe
dire le premier c'est un opportuniste il
il
contradicteurcteur pardonnez-moi il y a
une autre faille dans votre raisonnement
c'est ce que vous appelez les
manifestations pour la paix il y a un
mélange de gens qui sont sincèrement
attachés à la cause palestinienne
mélanger à des gens qui portent des
autocollants à la gloire des types qui
ont découpé des bébés et mélanger à des
gens qui vous disent les massacres en
Israël n'ont pas existé donc c'est
mélangé dans ces manifestations avec des
négationistes avec des négationistes en
direct
que vous appelez des manifestations pour
la toutes les manifestations des Feurs
de
merde majorité des gens qui vont
manifest c'est parce que ils sont
choqués par le nombre impressionnant de
gens qui meurent en Palestine en ce
moment et de laisser
per la majorité
mer par non maispement parce que non
j'ai commencé par les autres j'ai
commencé par les autres j'ai commencé
par les
autrescé manif moi je trouve ça très
bien a une manifestation là autorisée
pour le moment organisé ou monter par
LFI ce weekend pour
soutenir monter par LFI c'est une
pression très juste oui mais je viens de
le dire monage non mais non mais
attendez laissez-moi finir une phrase je
trouve ça très bien que non mais je
trouve ça très bien que les gens bah non
mais j'ai le droit de parer non mais je
vais pas dans les manies je vais pas les
man compqué voilà je trouve ça très bien
que les gens qui sont pro Palestiniens
manifestent en France ça a été trop on
l'a tous dit ici on l'a tous dit ici on
l' de la France insoumise Boyard vient
de dire notre objectif c'est la panique
dans la rue c'est son tweet qui vient de
sortir sortez mais attendez vous êtes
total je dis les manifestations et je
dis
manifestation je parle des manif et je
c une manifestation organisée par la
France les G qui V manifester c'est
parce qu'ils ont envie ont envie que les
gens arrê de crever sous les
bombes je vous dire les gens qui
organisent les manifestations il av pas
besoin de la France insoumise mais
oui mais c'est très
bienis je vis qu'on voie la vidéo d'é no
hier soir hier sur ces news
regardez mon métier c'est de commenter
mais là je peux pas plus non c'est trop
dur
bon c'est trop de ça fait depuis le 7
octobre effectivement qu'on est tous
sous cette charge émotionnelle et
imaginez qu'on puisse en arriver à
mettre un bébé vivant dans un fou pour
je comprends votre émotion
Eric alors ça c'était hier chez notre
ami Laurence Ferrari vous avez été
submergé par l'émotion éic nolo bah ce
qui est étonnant c'est pas que je cède à
l'émotion et que je pleure c'est ce qui
est étonnant c'est que tout le monde ne
pleure pas je trouve en France oua quand
on quand on entend le récit de ces
abominations je crois que c'est le
moment de pleurer en tout cas que chacun
réagisse selon sa propre sensibilité
mais c'est certainement pas le le moment
des petits calcul politique à la
Mélenchon voà France insoumise voilà ce
que je dis quand on a le cœur au bon
endroit et le cerveau au bon endroit on
est déjà solidaire des victimes et quand
on parle de victimes il y il y a pas eu
d'acte aussi atroce depuis le nazisme en
réalité ces gens-là sont des nazis et
sur ces agissements là vous avez des
gens qui disent est-ce que ce sont
vraiment des terroristes un bébé vivant
dans un four et ventrer une femme
enceinte est-ce que c'est vraiment
terroriste juste monsieur le député il
il y a beaucoup de gens aussi j'ai vu
sur les réseaux qui disent que c'est une
c'est une fausse information est-ce que
tu une vraie information ou pas mais la
barbarie c'est une vraie information
j'ai vu les camignons frigorifiques
s'ouvrir devant
moi je les ai vu j'ai entendu cette dame
me dire de manière totalement
sincère il y a un enfant et une mère qui
ont été brûlé vif ensemble j'ai vu
l'odeur insoutenable ce qui est
révoltant dans ce que fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que il aurait dû dire
que c'était des crimes contre l'humanité
enfin bon sens c'est quand même pas
compliqué de dire que c'est des crimes
d'une barbarie sans nom et une fois
qu'il a dit ça madame vous avez raison
il aurait pu dire on parle d'histoire on
réfléchit on parle de paix mais il
aurait dû commencer par dire c'est des
crimes d'une barbarie sans n on a tué 30
français tout le monde s'en fout il y a
neu aotages il y a nef
aotages mais non non mais il y a
neages il y a ne aages juste dire une
chose j'ai grandi moi avec à la
télévision les bandeaux de George
malbruno et d'v gekier ils sont où les
bandeaux dans notre pays pour demander
la libération des neuf otages vous
parler de manifestation je terminerai là
moi je suis pour des manifestations pour
la paix est-ce qu'il y a un drapeau
israélien est-ce qu' parle des des
otages il y a pas eu une mention dans
les manifestations sur la libération des
nototages il y a neu français
aujourd'hui qui sont des compatriotes il
y a pas de mention c'est pas des
rassemblements pour la paix des
rassemblements pour la paix on parle des
otages on parle des français morts il y
a des drapeaux israéliens et
palestiniens ça c'est magifque P je vous
montrer je vais vous montrer une vidéo
c'est la vidéo qui a fait le plus parler
aujourd'hui c'est une publication en
ligne évoquant le le meurtre d'un bébé
qui aurait été brûlé dans un four et
aujourd'hui cette vidéo fait énormément
parler c'est une influenceuse enfin une
influenceuse une une abrutie plutôt qui
a traité ce sujet avec une ironie
insoutenable je sais pas si vous avez vu
cette
vidéo regardez non mais c'est une folle
mais bon c'est une folle mais ça circule
sur les réseaux et ça a été énormément
vu donc les chéris quand on parle des
réseaux un moment un moment il faut
vraiment que les mecs se réveill comm la
vidéo des jeunes les mecs se réveillent
sur les réseaux parce que ça devient
n'importe quoi et je vous dis et ça ça a
énormément circulé avant d'être enlevé
donc regardez cette vidéo abusé moi il y
a une chose qui me qui me ture le pine
je je je je vais je vais je vais vous
donner le fond de ma pensée sans filtre
à chaque fois que je tombe sur
l'histoire du bébé qui a été mis dans le
four je me pose la question de si ont
mis du sel du poivre s'ils ont mis du
thin ils l'ont fait revenir à quoi et
euh et ça a été quoi
l'accompagnement vous posez pas la
question vous je sais pas accompagnement
avec ce gigot de bébé n'était qu'autre
qu'une assiette de frites avec une sauce
ketchup et
mayonnaise et on l'a mariné avec du sel
du thint et avec une sauce
pas mal moi je trouve que c'est un un
menu plutôt pas mal c'est grave c'est là
o mélange ça ça ça ça c'est une vidéo
qui a circulé ça est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte moi je pense pas que ce
soit marginal moi je pense qu'il y a un
antisémitisme très très important dans
notre pays notre P on s'en rend pas
compte Areuse aussi qui marchait sur le
drapeau israélien je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu une vidéo pareil où elle
décrit son look et cetera et où elle dit
ah j'ai pas oublié Israël et elle a sous
la chaussure sous sa semelle le drapeau
israélien ça être interdit
terroris mais là là c'est insoutenable
c'est là où les hommes c'est là où les
hommes politiques et les médias ont un
ont un devoir c'est que ils sont en
train d'infuser ils sont en train
d'infuser de libérer une parole et comme
par hasard on a toute une série comme ça
de débiles mentaux qui bascule dans le
négationnisme ou dans l'antisémitisme et
c'est ça le problème ce dont on parle
avec guillaumis tu me parles tu me
parles de je suis char non tu peux pas
être Charlie lorsqu'il s'agit de
basculer dans quelque chose qui est
interdit ça tombe sous le coup de la loi
c'est du racisme pur et dur on ne peut
pas l'excuser parce que c'est un
humoriste ou un mec intelligent je m'en
fous tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est que la France insoumise est en
train de libérer tout un tas de dingues
il désinh la parole il désinhible la
parole vous avez tout à fait raison et
après on se retrouve avec ces gens-là
qui attisent la haine qui creusent la
société qui nous fracture c'est
terrible c'est contre c'est contre un
des trois principe de la République la
fraternité la fraternité ils sont en
contravention fait la vidé je vous
remercie monsieur les députés je vous
remercie éic nolo d'avoir été avec nous